Speaker 1: OK, let's jump in to our audience
questions for the week.
First question is, David, we know Joe Biden
is polling quite well from a standpoint of
approval, but why isn't Kamala Harris nearly
as popular as Joe Biden?
So I didn't even know about this.
I looked into it.
And it's true.
Kamala Harris, his approval rating is quite
a bit lower.
Economist YouGov poll has about 51 percent
approval for Joe Biden, only 41 percent approval
for Kamala Harris, lower certainly outside
of the margin of error.
In a more recent poll, Harris was at 26, very
favorable with Joe Biden, 33 at very favorable.
There is a gap.
It's not a massive gap.
And given that, I don't find it hugely surprising
that Kamala Harris is not polling as well
as Joe Biden for a few different reasons.
First of all, she was never as popular as
Joe Biden during the primaries.
There was a period there, I think, when she
had that bomb drop moment about Biden being
racist or something during a debate where
she gained a little bit and then she very
quickly, within a couple of weeks, lost that
and she was never super popular.
So unless there's some reason why she would
now be very popular, it's not surprising to
me that she's not doing super well as far
as approval.
The second piece of it is Joe Biden often
talks about the Biden Harris administration
and Kamala Harris is often there at different
things.
But she's not been particularly present as
a major player in a lot of the things that
are what makes Joe Biden popular today.
I'm not saying she wasn't a major player.
I'm saying it just hasn't been apparent from
much of the way that the stories have been
covered.
Covid stimulus, for example, it really was
framed as this is Biden negotiating and then
Democrats in the House and Senate getting
it done.
And Harris is there in the room, as has often
been said, but she's not sufficiently connected
to it.
And then lastly, there is a kind of personality
aspect, which is, as the vice president, she
hasn't taken the spotlight.
Now, some may say, well, she's not been allowed
to.
That may be I'm not saying that she's chosen
not to.
I'm saying she hasn't been in the spotlight.
And that means that the discourse is sort
of happening around her more than being shaped
by her actions herself.
Now, there's one last thing on, and it's sort
of a propagandistic thing.
We've talked about how
Speaker 4: the
Speaker 1: Republican Party and right wing
media and others have concocted the immigration
crisis, the crisis at the border.
Now, the truth is things aren't much different
at the border than they were under Donald
Trump.
They've gotten significantly better actually
in the last six weeks, which we've reported
on.
But the the narrative has been it's a border
crisis.
And it worked in that back in June, only 28
percent of the country thought there was a
crisis at the border last month.
Forty eight percent of the country believe
there was a crisis at the border.
So the propaganda has worked.
How does this relate to Comilla?
It relates to Kamala Harris because she was
designated as the person who was going to
handle the situation at the border.
Now, if you believe it's a crisis and you
believe what Fox News says, that nothing's
been done and you remember that it was assigned
to Kamala Harris, you probably don't have
a particularly high view of favorable view
of Kamala Harris.
So I think that the negativity around that
probably is not is not helping her either.
That's my sense.
Never really popular to begin with.
Not in the spotlight for Joe Biden's successes.
And I don't want to say thrown under the bus,
but tied to.
A fabricated so-called crisis at the border
because it was assigned to her portfolio and
the right wing media narrative is just that
the crisis continues regardless of what the
truth is there.
Send me your thoughts if you have a different
view as to why Carmella's approval is lower
than than Biden's.
And last thing, I think generally the vice
president has a lower approval than the president.
I think it was the case with Mike Pence and
Donald Trump for most of his presidency.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
I'm going from memory.
It doesn't strike me as shocking for that
reason either.